Daisy va-t-elle porter chance à l'équipe
de France le chien de l'ambassade des
États-Unis à Paris en tout cas choisi la
gamelle de la victoire et elle est bleue
blanche rouge plusieurs fois donc il va
dire c'est pas comme la première la
première fois ça avait été exceptionnel
en 98 c'est vrai que d'ailleurs on avait
vu une audience des hommes politiques
etc c'était une folie là je dirais pas
qu'on prend l'habitude parce que ça
serait un peu exagéré mais ça prend ça
voilà dans la capitale la station de
métro argentine a disparu elle a été
renommée France allait les Bleus en ce
jour de finale la France et l'Argentine
on n'a pas de passif politique voyez
avec le Maroc il y avait plus d'enjeux
un peu plus compliqué mais franchement
avec l'Argentine le rapport c'est
essentiellement du football quoi donc on
gagne on est ravis on gagne pas bon ben
on n'a pas gagné mais je veux dire il y
a pas de papiers il y a pas d'histoire
colonial il y a rien derrière l'aéroport
de Nice a lui annoncé un vol vers la
troisième étoile décollage prévu à 16
heures
les derniers supporters français se sont
eux envolés cette nuit pour le Qatar
et ils se sont bien échauffés la voix
c'était un rêve que je voulais réaliser
c'est voilà j'ai mon billet d'avion et
j'ai ma place pour la finale de la Coupe
du Monde des Bleus au Qatar et voilà
j'entends tellement je suis heureux et
on a vu du point de vue des spectateurs
on a vu que le football
on n'a pas vu la toile de fond
l'arrière-plan qui probablement est
sujet à discussion polémique mais ce qui
est ce qui a frappé c'est la qualité des
installations en plus d'une troisième
étoile les Bleus pourraient décrocher ce
soir le gros lot une prime de champion
du monde offert au vainqueur par
l'organisation de 40 millions d'euros un
montant en augmentation par rapport à il
y a 4 ans enthousiasme pas toujours
partager par les anciens de l'équipe de
France Michel Platini Laurent Blanc et
Zinédine Zidane ne seront pas du voyage
au Qatar tout comme Karim Benzema pas
intéressé type de France
[Rires]
sur les 40 millions que pourrait toucher
la Fédération Française 12 millions
iront au joueur et aux membres du staff
comme Didier Deschamps chacun aura donc
droit à 400000 €. je vous appelle
monsieur le Président maintenant non
vous pouvez m'appeler comme d'habitude
[Rires]
ça doit vous rajeunir cette bouffée de
sociabilité de chaleur d'optimisme
d'optimisme de positivité je pense
qu'elle évite la récession je le dis
président de la République le sait en
cas de sacre mondial sa cote de
popularité pourrait repartir à la hausse
cette aubaine serait bienvenu pour le
président de la République face à un
climat morose en France plombé par
l'inflation et la guerre en Ukraine là
il y a quelque chose de positif qui tire
l'économie française on se donne des
rendez-vous des rendez-vous
des rendez-vous de spectateurs on
consomme plus donc on consomme plus mais
aussi à la cafette au bureau on en parle
et ça crée enfin je stéréotypes un peu
mais oui oui moi je sens ça positivement
la commission d'enquête parlementaire
constituée par le Parlement européen
devrait d'après cette résolution
enquêter une fois la faire judiciaire
terminée c'est à dire donc obamo pas
avant 5 ou 6 ans honnêtement c'est une
c'est une c'est pour ça que vous l'avez
pas nous avons déposé un amendement pour
que cette commission d'enquête
parlementaire elle est lieu dès
maintenant et tout le Parlement européen
l'a refusé et puis une image pour
terminer celle du sourire rayonnant et
satisfait de la nouvelle Miss France
pour l'année 2023 elle s'appelle Indira
en Pio jusque la Miss Guadeloupe tout
juste 18 ans étudiante en communication
donc je crains qu'il y ait d'autres
cadavres dans le placard j'ai vu des
articles en Belgique qui parle d'une
soixantaine de députés européens qui
sont corrompus qui aurait reçu de
l'argent du Qatar mais en vérité on sait
que le Qatar arrose la classe politique
française et européenne depuis 10 ans